you know the process is  um whatever it needs to be for that uh  uh for whatever I'm doing I I envy  people uh who you know they they talk  about how they go to the office at 9am  and they write 20 pages and they go home  at six o'clock and and they're with  their families my life is nothing like  that  um most of the time writing is spent not  writing uh it it's spent uh climbing the  walls uh trying to figure out what to do  I've never written an outline I'll write  index cards but only  three or four maybe five uh in a row  it's like walking ahead in the dark with  a flashlight you can really only see as  far as you go but the further you walk  uh the further you can see and then once  you have the ending it's something to to  write toward